don't need as as Muslims we don't need
the New Testament we don't need the Old
Testament so why does your Quran tell us
to judge by the gospel because they used
to go to Muhammad to ask him for
judgment so why do you come to
Muhammad so why did they come why did
they come to Muhammad to to ask for
judgment but this this is what I this
what I wanted to say to you Christians
never did that I'm sorry Christians
never did that the Jews did to try to
trick
Muhammad and then responds with why do
they come to you when they have the
Torah thus proving my point again that
they don't need the Quran and then the
next verse says the same for the people
of the Gospel the Christians judged by
the gospel by what Allah has revealed in
in their books by what Allah has
revealed in their books so if they have
the re revelation of God in their books
they supposed to use
that for judgment they don't need but
also the Quran is supposed to be a muham
a GU a guardian for the previous books
because it's it's correcting the Mis
misconceptions that may have AR arose in
between Revelations does that make sense
got you so so let me ask you this go
ahead um if you don't need but hold on
hold on for a second let me ask you a
question do I get to ask you after I
answer your questions as long as it's on
topic I I have no problem with it back
and forth as long as it's on topic what
was the topic I missed that we're we're
on it right now we're on
it no I wanted a cold one yeah I wanted
a cold one you wanted a what a cold one
okay yeah go ahead bro we're on the
topic right
now
so when Muhammad had doubts about his
Revelations what what did Allah tell him
to do in the Quran do you know so let me
so this is the thing even if he he say
go to the people who have knowledge for
them to uh to tell you how Revelation
happens that still doesn't mean that you
should believe everything they tell you
wait a second like like let me let me
ask you hold on hold on on hold on
for if Muhammad needed if Muhammad had
doubts and even he needed to the Bible
to do away with those doubts according
to Allah what makes you think that
you're different no but this the thing
the Arabs they didn't have they didn't
have prophets the Jews and the
Christians they had prophets so you go
to them and ask hey man do you have
prophets coming to you God does God
speak to people and reveal Revelations
to you that's the question that you go
and ask because he in the beginning he
felt like what's happening to me what's
happening to me how am I getting this
Revelation where is this coming from and
than and he's telling them he's going to
them hey man does this happen and they
clarify that to him so it's not like hey
man huh no they didn't clarify that he
was a prophet that's not what happened
yeah he went to he went
to
you wara died by the time this verse was
revealed he was already
dead so then then it wasn't then he then
the ver the verse wasn't for Muhammad
then
because you and me it's talking to you
and me but it literally says it's
talking about Muhammad now so come on
man what verse are we talking about what
verse are we talking about chapter 10
verse 94 what does he say chapter 10
verse 94 it says if you talking about
Muhammad if you are in doubt about the
revelations that has been what has been
revealed to
you the book nah man that does not talk
about Muhammad I'm telling you Muhammad
he knew he was a prophet he knew you
know what you know what let me Grant it
to you let's say it's talking about you
as a Muslim today so you just proed to
me that you as a Muslim need my Bible no
so if I have doubts but I don't have
doubts really yeah I don't have doubts
all right do you believe that Jesus
mentioned
Amman yeah
where who is the Holy Spirit wait where
you getting this from yeah the holy
period the rabbi right there can can
verify where you wait why you no no
don't ask me to verify you might regret
that yeah where where are you getting
this from there's no regrets bro no
regrets let me let me let me ask you a
question no we got we got to keep it
here where are you getting this
from you saying that that's in the Bible
I didn't say anything about the Bible
are you quo the Bible right now what was
your question what was your question my
question was simple yeah where does
Jesus mention
Muhammad you mentioned the Holy Spirit
it says that in in the
Quran yes it says Jesus said that a
messenger named ammed will come after
him where do I
find now are you asking me where do you
find that in the
Bible I'm asking you where do I find
Jesus saying that
period you find it in the Quran no the
Quran is a claim the Quran quotes and
put words in Jesus's mouth yeah that
Jesus mentioned a man a person named
amid will come after him how do I verify
that how do I verify that the Quran is
telling the truth about what Jesus said
where do I where do I go to find this
statement from Jesus no but if you
already if you already believe in the
Quran you don't need the Bible I don't
believe in the Quran so what do I do
what it said if I don't believe in the
Quran what do I need to confirm this so
okay let me ask you a question if you go
to the Bible and you don't find answer
the question that I asked you please
this is this is what I'm answering
answer the question that I asked you
yeah I don't believe in the Quran so
what do I do where do I go to verify
that Jesus actually said this where do I
find his statement but also the Quran
says that the Bible are you gonna answer
the question this is me answering if you
let me do it I'll do it okay answer
directly where do I go to find out where
Jesus said this you want me to say the
the Bible and then you ex to go because
the Bible is not the Bible is not intact
so just because I didn't say the Bible
hey Adam did I did I mention the Bible
see that's what I'm saying for me I
already that oh no I didn't mention the
Bible radar did I mention the Bible
yet you did not you did not okay so I
quoted a verse from the Quran hold on SL
down right I quoted a verse from the
Quran okay that says Jesus said somebody
named Aid will come after him does the
Quran tell you where it's I don't so
does the Quran tell you verify hold on a
second so that you know how to answer
okay I'm trying I don't believe in the
Quran so I'm trying to
verify if the Quran is
true so how do I where do I go to verify
this statement of Jesus that he actually
said amid is coming after him where do I
go to find from
Jesus okay so M does the Quran tell you
where you can go to find it nope so if
the Quran doesn't tell you where to go
and find it then the verification should
be I need to verify whe whether the
Quran is from God or not now if it's
from God then the Quran is telling the
truth if you go to the Bible and you
don't find it then the then the Bible is
not the Bible must being changed you
know what you know what's wrong with
this what's what's wrong with that yeah
your Quran says that it is a detailed
explanation of everything so it should
have told me where I can find the
statement from Jesus if it's missing
that detail then the Quran is false
still you see how that works Quan if
it's the detail for for everything that
happened then we should know like the
Quran should tell us how long the the
word existed but the Quran doesn't tell
you that the Quran doesn't tell you that
the Quran is is the detailed explanation
on
how continuing to show me that your Quan
is listen but listen listen to me for a
second big bro you know let me talk no I
want you to talk on the point don't
waffle on something else talk okay then
the Quran is a detailed explanation on
how one is supposed to leave their life
doesn't say that it says it's a detailed
explanation of everything that's what it
says on how you're supposed to leave
your life it doesn't say everything on
how you're supposed to it says
everything period so so so what makes it
right for you to say everything per
period because the Quran says everything
period see the okay the Quran says the
Quran also says that this is a book that
has been revealed for those who need
guidance to God so does guidance to God
mean what do I eat uh uh how long the
world existed did the Quran mention how
long did it mention creation is guidance
is guidance is is it part of the Quran
mention the world and its creation yes
or no it does yeah okay so if it's
detailed about everything it should tell
me how long the world has been in
existence if it doesn't it's lacking how
is that supposed to help you in guidance
to God look I I want you to pay
attention to what I'm saying you have
point you would have a point Sai if the
verse said it's detailed about
everything concerning your guidance you
would have a point do say that though he
does say that it does say that it does
say that
it does say
that okay you said it says that let's
see let's see if you're right or I'm my
right you
ready go ahead Big Brother all right
this is your channel I know it is it's
my
show this what we do here I hear I like
to teach Quran here man man you're
missing the point B that's what I'm
trying to tell you man the Quran is the
Quran the Quran is a a guidance for for
mankind it's not go watch this it's not
okay look at this chapter 12 verse
111 there was certainly in their stories
a lesson for those who of understanding
right never was the Quran a narration
invented but a confirmation of what came
before it and a detailed explanation of
all
things and a guidance and a mercy for
people who believe that's it it says it
right there does it say that says it
right there does it say it's an
explanation of just your guidance or
does it say an explanation of all
things okay on on this on this on this
uh chapter can you answer and can you
answer any question I need you to
acknowledge it does it say that it's an
explanation of all things or does it say
that it's an explanation of just your
guidance explanation of all things thank
you so if the Quran mentions something
it should be giving a detailed
explanation of everything about that
particular thing
correct so you got your own narrative
that you want to you know put out my
narrative is the Quran but okay so let
me let me answer let me answer it from
my way because you know every like you
like you say this is your channel you
can everything that goes on my my my
answer is this my answer is this if the
Quran mentions something it should give
me all the details on that said thing
correct okay yeah
okay so if the Quran says Jesus said
something it should tell me how I can
verify that
right okay so this is the question if it
doesn't tell me where I can verify this
then that means that the Quran is
lacking details in that
right okay which would mean that the
Quran is false because it says it's a
detailed explanation of
everything get the
point you cherry picking and me I don't
do be I I don't want to do this cherry
picking uh narration this is what I'm
saying it says it right there on that
verse that this is a guidance for
mankind it says it right there if it was
for detailed expl explanation for all
things that happened even that that that
chapter right there Yousef it doesn't
even tell you who his mother was he
doesn't even tell you how long he stayed
in jail he doesn't even tell you so it's
not it's not a detailed explanation for
all things like the way you want to
think about it it's a detailed
explanation on guidance for mankind so
the Quran doesn't do that so the Quran
is not a detailed explanation of all
things is that correct it's a detailed
explanation of all things you just told
me things that it's not detailed
on don't waste my time man
I don't know what to tell I'm tell me
this is what you can tell me Islam is
false logic I'm sorry that I came up
here prideful you got a good point here
Islam I'm no but that's a that's a
that's a false
uh it's it's a false uh you you lying to
people because that's what I'm well name
the LIE name the lie I like when people
like come up I like when people like you
come up but let me ask you a question
let me ask you a question about
the
lying you do this ad you don't have a
right to ask me anything you want a
detailed explanation for all things that
book will be that book that's what the
Quran says though but that that book
will be the biggest book in the
world that's what it claims though
that's what it claims though Quan say if
the Quran says something should I
believe
it yeah 100% okay so it says it's a
detailed explanation of all things
should I not hold the Quran to what it
says okay what other what explanation
apart from that it didn't tell you where
to go find where Jesus said uh Ahmed is
to come after him what other uh
explanation to that you don't like that
was on in the Quran what do you mean
that I don't like told me it doesn't
mention how long Joseph was in jail it
doesn't mention who Joseph's mother was
it doesn't mention the the the the the
wife of Adam doesn't because that's not
the reason why the Quran was revealed
that's what I'm trying to get you to
understand but the Quran says it's like
that everything everything you're coming
to me you're just showing me that the
Quran is false the Quran lied to all of
us when it said it's detailed about
everything it
lied it lied you're you're a funny dude
bro you're I know man that's what they
tell me right by what you want to ask
about no no there's no switching of
you're stuck
here detail of all things yeah so now
let's try this let's try this again when
the Quran says that Jesus mentioned
somebody named opment to come after him
where can I find where Jesus said this I
believe the
Quran where can I Jesus said this I
believe the Quran okay you believe thean
why can't you understand that let me ask
you a different one can I try explain it
to him nope from Islamic perspective
nope in chapter 7 verse 157 no because
he was prideful Adam I gotta I gotta
treat him like this because he was
prideful yeah in chapter 7 verse 157 it
says that we will find Muhammad written
in the Torah and the injil with
us where can I find him in the gospel
with us Isaiah
42 Isaiah 42 is the
gospel oh you say say that one more time
it you
can
it says you can find that we can find
Muhammad written in the Torah and the
gospel with us yeah so Isaiah is part of
the Torah isn't it no it's not oh it's
not okay but you don't you don't have
the
gospel I don't have the gospel okay what
is the
gospel what was revealed to Jesus what
is that you have that
the inil is revealed to Jesus do you
have it that's still not telling me
anything what is that the good news
right what is that specifically what is
it is it a what is it I'm saying it I
think I'm saying it so wait wait how do
how do let me ask you this how do you
know that I don't have the
gospel because it says Gospel according
to Matthew that's not know it says the
Gospel of Jesus according to Matthew so
Matthew wrote down the gospel of Jesus
does he say that P pull up pull up what
he said yeah that's the title that's the
title on every page it's the Gospel of
Jesus according to Matthew if you pull
up
Mark first of Mark says goel Jesus the
very first the very first verse of Mark
let me show you the very first verse of
Mark literally says this is the Gospel
of
Jesus here you
go here you go Habibi you GNA learn
today man yeah I'm trying
good maybe you can come out of the
darkness of Islam and humble yourself is
that right that's right sounds good I
know it sounds excellent man you'll be
with me celebrating with my brothers and
sisters look at this now bro you see it
you look at the
screen Mark chapter one literally the
first verse it says what is this what is
Mark Writing the beginning of the Gospel
of Jesus Christ the son of God
yeah but I'm saying I'm looking for the
gospel that Jesus taught because when
gospel was going when Jesus was going
around he wasn't going around saying the
beginning of the Gospel of Jesus
according to Mark get what I'm saying I
get what you're saying was the Gospel
written that I don't know your Quran
says it was your Quran says the verse
that I've been quoting to you they will
find
Muhammad written in the Torah and the
gospel with them so the gospel was
written now you know okay so it was
written okay yeah who wrote it
but I'm looking for the one that Jesus
wrote yeah who wrote Jesus wrote it down
wait where Jesus you said Jesus wrote
show me in the Quran where it says Jesus
wrote it but I'm saying the gospel was
revealed to Jesus yeah who wrote
it so show me the one can you show me
the Quran that Muhammad
uh Muhammad was illiterate and you
should know this so you understand that
Revelation is not the same as writing
down so the gospel was revealed to Jesus
who wrote the Gospel but okay so if you
want to use that then how come we don't
write like when you go into the Quran it
doesn't on let me make my point big bro
when you go to the Quran it doesn't say
that hey uh this is the Quran according
to
Muhammad it doesn't say this is Quran
according to abaka it doesn't say this
is the you're actually right here's
what's interesting about that's what I'm
looking for for the this is Quran says
in chapter 89 verse1 17 it says this is
the word of a noble
messenger that's what your Quran says
the know jel it's not clear in detail
it's
gibel oh jabril so it's I thought it was
the word of
Allah that
stupid got it no you didn't no that's
not got it right man listen I like I
like that
reaction because you're stupid bro in
your head and I'm sorry I I I don't mean
I don't mean to insult you my bad I
should take that back because I'm fast
it's okay bro I don't mind that I don't
I don't mind I'm taking it back bro I'm
taking it back I'm taking it back
because I'm fasting and and you being
nice and robbi didn't you just have a
drink didn't you just have a drink
my wife my wife she's my wife the women
they don't fast all days okay all right
just asking yeah thank you though thank
you thank you for keeping me honest but
I am fasting so who the
gopel that's what I'm saying it's not my
it's not my prerogative I don't need to
I I don't don't you believe in it I
believe the one that was revealed to
Muhammad that's my point there was no
gospel revealed to Muhammad bro it's in
it's in the Quran
there was no gospel that was the verse
you said the verse you said the verse
you said that Jesus said that a
Messenger will come after him named
Ahmed uhuh that is the gospel that's the
gospel nice now who wrote it
yeah I wasn't
there okay so let me ask you this go
ahead let me see if I can reason when
when do I get put when do I get to put
my question in when I see that you
deserve
it man all right bro go ahead it's tough
man so let me ask you would it make
sense to you if Jesus didn't write if
Jesus didn't write his uh his the gospel
um that maybe that maybe his disciples
his companions would have wrote it down
for him yeah makes perfect sense okay
and so it makes perfect sense that the
disciples would have written down the
gospel yeah I believe that too makes
perfect sense yeah and so what we have
is what is claimed to be written by the
Disciples of Jesus but no no because uh
somebody irns I believe irns 180
something years later say that this is
what M Mark wrote so he attributed the
names yeah Mark he said Mark wrote it at
the dictation of Peter Peter couldn't
couldn't write so he wrote it for Peter
the disciple also hold on let me ask you
let me ask you a question do you know
the point not even B Ammon but do you
know James tab you know James tab no
you're I need you to focus don't go off
the
point these are Bible scholars we have
what is written no we have what is
written by the disciples we have what is
written what makes sense to you you
believe the same thing that I do that
the Gospel of Jesus was written by his
disciples why are you saying that what I
have is not the Gospel of Jesus there
because what I believe is that
Jesus himself wouldn't claim to be God
and there's no claiming for him to be
God in the in the Bible that you have
right now he doesn't claim to be God so
then mean that itches the go let me let
me make a point let me make a point but
I I if somebody else from the helenistic
world claims that Jesus was God then I'm
not supposed to believe that because the
Quran comes here some 600 years later no
that's that's precise the point so you
said that you don't believe my gospel
because you don't believe that Jesus
claimed to be God but you also just said
that nowhere in my Bible does Jesus
claim to be God
correct yeah yeah so then that means
that my gospel matches your theological
beliefs so why do you deny it your
understanding of it okay you reject my
understanding got you so I misunderstand
my Bible my gospel however it's still
the correct gospel
right I can't say with 100% certainty
why
not because some things are changed some
some things are taken out some some
things are put back in so it's like what
I don't know what to believe just more
claims know to believe just more claims
I no you don't need to have claims you
can let me let me ask you this let me
ask you this I don't need to make claims
if you let me if you let me make a point
I can show you it's not a claim how did
Jesus how did Jesus
pray I don't
know excellent answer um you believe
that Jesus is the
Messiah
yes did Jesus what language did Jesus
speak Hebrew or aric one of how do you
know
that because uh from his from history
yeah where does history get it from that
Jesus spoke Aramaic in
Hebrew if you go to the first century
the the Jews at that time they spoke
Aramaic how do you know that Jesus lived
in the first century and spoke Aramaic
in
Hebrew you got the Roman Empire that was
the first century how do you know that
Jesus lived in the first century with
the Jews in the first century and spoke
Aramaic this I don't I don't get the
point you're trying to make me bro to be
honest just answer the question
you'll
see because that's one two three
everybody knows that you know yeah
common you're right it's common
knowledge but common knowledge has a
foundation right it's based on something
what is it based on that Jesus lived in
the first century and spoke Hebrew and
Aramaic living under the rule of the
Roman Empire Joseph where does that come
from
Josephus my goodness Josephus comes
after the disciples his writing is later
than that
where do we get it from that Jesus spoke
Aramaic and Hebrew and lived in the
Roman Empire and lived in the first
century so josepher doesn't say that
wait just just really quick so you're
saying that Josephus is a good is good
to know information about
Jesus so I think so let me let me get uh
bring you back for a second because I'm
thinking that you asking me how do I
know that Jesus existed in the first
century yeah and I'm not trying to go
back to the Bible because that's what
you want to send me back to I'm saying I
don't need the Bible to know that Jesus
existed in the first century Josephus
Josephus nice I like that Joseph so
Josephus gives us accurate information
about the life of Jesus is that
correct no not necessarily he just says
that he you just said you just said
you're relying
on not saying that I'm relying on
Josephus to give me an accurate
information about Jesus I'm saying that
he gives us that somebody named Jesus
existed in the first century is that
your question let me ask I'm G ask you
again since you're saying now that
Joseph Joseph is is not reliable I'm
gonna ask you again I didn't even say
that how do you know that Jesus lived in
the didn't even I'm saying that you
asking me how do I know that Jesus lived
in the first century I'm saying
Josephus mentioned that somebody so is
that how you know Jesus oh my friend is
that how you know because Josephus
mentions that so you know that from
Josephus is that accurate okay yes okay
so then Josephus gives us accurate
information about the life of Jesus
correct so you want to go into this
Josephus saying this was Jesus yes or
does Joseph
give us accurate information on the life
of Jesus yes or no not necessarily not
means that Josephus is unreliable and
you can't trust him when he says Jesus
lived in the first century so then again
we're back at square one how Square One
is because the Quran says it okay good
now now this is fun show me in the Quran
where it says Jesus lived in the first
century it says in the Quran Jesus
existed it doesn't say show me in the
Quran where it says Jesus lived in the
first century it doesn't say it but you
just said that it said it no no I said
what you saying what do I need what how
do I know Jesus existed in the first
century I say Josephus but then you want
to say because Josephus
mentioned uh Jesus in the first century
you was saying Josephus is gives the
accurate information about the life of
Jesus
I'm saying that's not the case I'm
saying I could go to Josephus to make
sure that hey man Jesus it did exist in
the first century and go back to the
Quran to look at the accurate
information that Jesus and and how he
walked around how he was
born how do you know that Josephus is
right that he Liv that Jesus lived in
the first
century Jesus I mean uh Josephus is not
the only one mentioning it but you with
to Josephus you
so I'm saying you're wasting my
time get out of here don't don't don't
see get out of here you're wasting wild
you gave him a lot of time man you gave
him a lot of time